im phoenix tagesgespräch zu diesem
treffen der verteidigungsminister der
nato in brüssel ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann sie ist die
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin der
fdp-fraktion
frau strack-zimmermann was erwarten sie
denn von dem treffen der
verteidigungsminister heute in brüssel
also es sind ernste zeiten und ich
erwarte und hoffe dass die nato mit
einer stimme spricht denn wie ihr
beitrag gerade zeugte ist die situation
ernst es geht um durchaus bedrohungen
mit denen wir uns beschäftigen müssen
gerade was cyber bereich betrifft
kommunikationswege also sozusagen
bedrohungen die über das in
anführungszeichen klassische
bedrohungsszenario hinausgeht und es ist
gut dass die nato auch diesbezüglich
ihre doktrin anpasst es wird ja vor
allem ich habe es schon vorab gesagt um
afghanistan gehen und das große
scheitern so muss man es dann doch wohl
nennen was da stattgefunden hat würden
sie auch sagen dass da auch ein großer
teil der verantwortung bei den
amerikanern liegt weil der rückzug
ebenso rasant kam viel rasanter als man
dachte
ja so dass der rückzug kam bei kleine
überraschung donald trump hat ja bereits
die taliban hoffähig gemacht indem es in
doha gespräche gab ohne bedingungen also
man hat gesagt wir gehen raus und es
wurden keine bedingungen thema
menschenrechte frauenrechte gestellt das
war ein sehr sehr großer fehler das hat
deutschland die bundesregierung in der
form mitgetragen es gibt ja nato-rat wo
man diesbezüglich hätte etwas sagen
können wir haben das land verlassen mehr
fluchtartig als sortiert es gab keine
exit-strategie es gab keine evaluierung
der letzten jahre der einsätze sowie von
den freien demokraten gefordert und das
heißt dass wir in der tat jetzt schauen
müssen was in afghanistan passiert
primär erst mal dass dort eine große
humanitäre katastrophe als ich an warnt
der wir uns stellen und wo wir
verhindern müssen dass dieses passiert
und natürlich auch dass afghanistan
wieder nicht ein hort des terrorismus
wird denn wenn ich das noch sagen darf
es ist ja nicht alles gescheitert in
afghanistan der terror wurde bis sie
aber in der tat die gefahr jetzt wo
keiner mehr dort ist dass er wieder
aufblüht ist natürlich sehr groß unter
donald trump hat sich die am hat sich in
die usa ja sehr auf sich selbst besonnen
zurückgezogen erwarten sie da große
änderungen unter joe biden hat ja auch
schon gesagt dass man sich in erster
linie sozusagen am eigenen wohl
interessieren will auch
verteidigungspolitisch nein ich glaube
dass die amerikaner ihren weg gehen
stehen ja auch wahlen an und joe biden
hat das vollendet das was seine
vorgänger im grunde schon
begonnen haben nämlich das thema
afghanistan endlich hinter sich zu
lassen das ändert aber nichts daran dass
wir in der welt eine verantwortung für
diese region haben allein schon in
unserem interesse im interesse des
westens damit eben keine große
migrationswelle auf uns zukommt und dass
eben auch die humanitären gerecht die
humanitären rechte gewahrt sind ich darf
daran erinnern gerade weil wir so abrupt
abgezogen sind das ist wir bekommen auch
diese nachrichten dass es die
menschenrechte nicht verfolgt werden
dass frauen jetzt wieder zurück
katapultiert werden in eine zeit von der
wir glaubten dass wir sie überwunden
haben also allein deswegen haben wir
verantwortung zu übernehmen aber
diplomatische natur gegebenenfalls
irgendwann auch wieder was die
entwicklungshilfe betrifft da muss man
genau schauen das nicht unsere mittel
dazu verwandt werden die taliban
großzuziehen aber wir müssen schauen was
passiert mit den frauen vor ort und was
passiert eigentlich mit den orks kräften
die wir in der schnelle derzeit nicht
evakuiert haben also die menschen die
uns jahrelang die bundeswehr und die
nato begleitet haben als sprach und orts
vermittler und kulturvermittler die sind
noch da und sieht schweers gefährdet ja
ich möchte nochmal auf das nato treffen
heute zurückkommen es gibt ja große
verwerfungen mit russland die haben ihre
ständige vertretung bei der nato
geschlossen also die diplomatischen
drähte sozusagen gekappt wie schwierig
ist das verhältnis der nato zu russland
liebe wie besorgniserregend
ja es ist besorgniserregend aber auch
bedauerlich weil eins ist klar bei aller
diskussion auch unser unter
unterschiedlichen gesichtspunkten
unseres wertekanon ist es natürlich hoch
problematisch wenn man nicht mehr
miteinander spricht also dieser
gesprächsfaden muss immer wieder
versucht werden aufzunehmen und wenn es
hinter den kulissen ist aber eins muss
klar sein russland hand ambitionierte
ziel und wird das vakuum auch nutzen in
afghanistan jetzt wo die nato staaten
nicht mehr da sind und russland muss
wissen dass die nato ein friedliches
bündnis ist aber ein
verteidigungsbündnis und auch immer
bereit ist diese freie friedliche welt
des westens zu verteidigen und ich
glaube dass diese sprache der präsident
russlands versteht und deswegen muss man
auch entsprechend klar deutlich und
möglichst einheitlich auftreten
jetzt sind ja vermutlich teil einer
neuen regierung in deutschland als fdp m
was wird die nato sozusagen von dieser
neuen regierung erwarten können wenn es
nach ihnen geht
also wir werden in gespräche eintauchen
mit der sozialdemokratie und den grünen
ich glaube dass der zugang und dass wir
teil der nato sind wird uns einen die
frage wird eben sein wie wird die rolle
der bundesrepublik im rahmen der nato
seien die nato hat erwartungen an uns
auch verteidigungspolitisch und hat vor
allen dingen auch zu sagen von uns
bekommen die wir einhalten möchten und
einbehalten müssen und darüber wird zu
sprechen sein das bedeutet nämlich dass
die bundeswehr entsprechend ausgerüstet
sein muss das ist eine verpflichtung der
wir als freie demokraten nachkommen
wollen werden sie das schaffen sie
sitzen mit grün und rot im boot die ja
sicherlich eher richtungen ich sag mal
weniger bundeswehr weniger
rüstungsindustrie und so weiter gehen
wollen na ja es geht hier nicht um
rüstungsindustrie es geht darum dass wir
innerhalb der nato und wir sind ja nicht
nur teil der nato sondern werden ja auch
von der nato geschützt unseren teil dazu
beitragen wir können uns ja nicht wie
jahrzehntelang
hoffend dass wenn es mal ernst wird wenn
eine ernste situation kommen dass die
anderen länder die nato-mitglieder uns
dann schon helfen werden das werden sie
aber letztlich sind wir natürlich auch
in eigenverantwortung und wie die
auszusehen hat darüber werden wir
sprechen wir werden analysieren müssen
was haben wir zugesagt was fehlt was
kostet ist und gemeinsam und da bin ich
optimistisch genug einen weg gehen um
teil einer starken nato zu sein aber
eben auch der verpflichtung nachzukommen
als vierte reichstes land der erde
unseren teil dazu beizutragen
vielen dank marie agnes strack
zimmermann war dass die
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin der
fdp